Many desert plants get their water through
extensive root systems that burrow deep or spread wide.
But one type of moss gets its water right from the air;
its root-like structures hold the plant to the ground.
This plant’s panoply of water-collecting tricks
comes courtesy of tiny features on the
hair-like projections  at the end of each leaf,
called “awns”.
At the smallest scale, these awns
are covered with grooves about 100 nanometers
deep and 200 nanometers wide,
the perfect  size for dew to condense within them.
These nanogrooves lie within larger troughs
which are a good size to snag fog droplets from
the air.
Once enough moisture collects  in the microgrooves,
capillary action pulls the droplets toward the plant.
Voila! The plant waters itself.
And on the rare occasions when rain falls,
any droplets trapped between two awns
are likewise pulled toward the plant’s leaves.